I,
I think the situation has gone too far.
Uh,
it,
uh,
it will not be possible I think to get
the opposition to sit down with a sad.
So where,
where does that leave us?
In my view,
you have to,
um,
you have to try to level the playing
field and do so as quickly as possible.
Now we've seen the decisions,
uh,
in Istanbul a,
I can assure you there's a lot more
going on.
I'm,
I'm convinced,
uh,
beneath the radar.
I mean,
you know,
paying salaries to the FSA and what
exactly they're gonna be put on some
payroll or something.
Uh,
no,
I mean we need to get cash and a,
and a lot of it,
um,
to the opposition that there are ways to
encourage the process of defections a
that's already going on.
I think this has to be pursued as,
as energetically as possible in order to
hurt the asad regime and begin to get
the kind of balance where some kind of
negotiated outcome might be possible.
I don't think Roger,
just before we go on there,
when you say giving cash,
do you go further and say arms,
its arms,
arms,
cash,
uh,
logistics,
where with the,
I mentioned I'm not in,
I mean,
in an election year,
uh,
with Iran hovering in the background,
with Israel where it is on Syria,
uh,
I don't see a NATO planes in the skies
of a Siri.
I just,
I mean,
I,
I'm trying to deal here with realistic
options.
I don't regard that as a real estate
option.
Ain't going to happen,
at least not in my view.
So that leaves me,
um,
given that I don't think the Annan plan
can work,
that leaves me with a arm support
bolster
the FSA,
the rebels,
and try and get them to be as coherent
and effective as possible.